this one looks good oh boy
then after nearly an hour swimming like
a Tiger It's a tiger
there's a bite
got a beautiful tiger shark oh my God Dr
Austin Gallagher caught a tiger shark in
the Bermuda Triangle but it's not Mabel
it's a 12 foot long sexually mature male
hold it don't let it run don't let it
run not let it run
guys
this is a really strong shark
okay
finding a male tiger shark May mean one
thing it's mating season it's rare that
you see a large male shark of any
species in an area where there's a lot
of females when we saw him it only
supported our theory that they might be
mating here
in the Bahamas female tiger sharks seem
to prefer the company of their own
gender
some Sciences speculate that as a group
it's easier for female tiger sharks to
fend off unwanted sexual advances from
males
is this good yeah that's fine tie it off
and then come in mom and like hold
when you look at the distribution of
sharks we have what's called sexual
segregation which means that you find
males and females in different areas one
popular explanation is that females are
avoiding males outside of these mating
periods so it makes sense that if she
doesn't want to reproduce at that point
that she avoids that sort of mating
behavior altogether and that may explain
why you see females in separate areas
from where you find the males with
pregnancies that last up to 16 months
the female tiger sharks only mate once
every three years
when females are ready to mate it's
believed that they let the male tiger
sharks know by releasing pheromones if
so this male has likely caught a scent
and is on the search for a receptive
female that shark is definitely one of
the breeding males there's few of them
here we go boys
ahead yeah
all right
Dr Gallagher attaches a satellite tag to
the shark's dorsal fin
nice
satellite tags are awesome one of my
favorite tools these offer scientists
like us the chance to collect high
resolution data on the Sharks without us
having to follow them
the tag remains attached to the shark
recording Vital Information including
location depth and water temperatures
after several weeks the tag will pop off
float to the surface and transmit all
the data to a satellite
being able to get a mail with tag on it
that will actually reveal its depth
preferences and locations could actually
help us pinpoint exactly where these
animals are going too so that's really
valuable for our larger questions here
about mating vertical habitat use and
interactions between males and females
so getting a male is actually huge for
us tags in fin clip hey I'm taking a
little think up here
a thin clip
study the genetic genetiversity of these
tiger sharks in the Bermuda Triangle Dr
Gallagher Clips the dorsal fin for Blood
and Tissue samples
these are going to provide invaluable
insights into the genetics and the
hormones and stress levels of these
animals oh he's ready to go
these are pieces of the puzzle that
we're going to put together to
understand how valuable the Bermuda
Triangle is for sharks
nicely done guys wow that's a huge shark
[Music]